- Hi, my name's Alon Shaya, and
today, we're talking hummus.
My favorite is kinda like the
classic hummus with tahini,
which we're doing today,
but my rule of thumb is
everything goes good on hummus.
So, the baking soda really
begins to break down
the structure of the skins
that are on top of the garbanzo beans.
When you soak them in it,
it starts to break it down a little bit,
but then when you drain it
and bake it with a lot more,
it really dries on there and
really starts to break down
all that cell structure of the skins.
And so, now, when we go to rinse it,
those skins will just
kind of start to fall off.
I'm kind of massaging the beans to get the
baking soda off of it,
but also to get the skins
to start coming off,
and that's what's gonna
really make it nice and tender
is as those skins fall off,
you get a very smooth puree.
The hummus was one of the
major major things for us.
We made, I think, 80
batches before we got it
right where we wanted it.
If we didn't get the hummus right,
we wouldn't be standing here right now.
You want 'em to be falling
apart, super mushy.
When you sit down in an
Arab restaurant in Israel,
you typically get plates of hummus
and then you get plates
of Moroccan carrot salad
and pickled cauliflower and
tabouleh and baba ghanoush
and tahini and maybe some grated tomato
and extra virgin olive
oil and a little sea salt
and spicy peppers, and
then you get all this pita,
and then that's kinda
the way your meal starts.
And we were very particular
to not cut the bread
into little triangles or whatever,
or serve it with a knife.
We wanted people to grab it, tear it open,
burn their fingers, and then
feel that kind of connection
where you're passing
somebody a piece of bread
and then you're grabbing a plate
and then you're sharing this
and you're making bites for people.
That's really kind of the beauty
of the food that we cook, I think.
(upbeat music)